give them more
like any great fighting game street
fighter 5 is magnet once you start
fighting win or lose you're attracted to
the thrill of it all any concerns that
the game's new mechanics would feel
foreign were quickly dashed and replaced
by the ever-present joys of chipping
away at the eccentricities these tweaks
introduce Street Fighter 5 feels new and
familiar at the same time and it's
reignited my desired flight we received
the game less than a week ago and I'm
quickly falling for its mechanics which
add to rather than take away from the
importance of fundamental skills and
measured play this is unlike street
fighter forest focus attack which was
designed to cover mistakes as much as it
enabled maximizing damage in the hands
of a casual player these tools are
satisfying wrinkles that can deal high
damage with low execution demands at
higher levels however their technical
and strategic tools that demand a great
degree of understanding and master
Street Fighter 5 requires deliberate
planning and execution where you could
rely on chaos to do some of your work
for you in street fighter 4 you now need
to be hyper aware of when to act and
when to observe as reckless behavior
rarely amounts to a positive outcome
crucially I haven't had enough
experience playing online to develop a
well informed opinion of the network
components of the game Capcom is still
in the process of tweaking its servers
ahead of launch unless our ability to
fight over the internet has been
sporadic when I was able to fight online
the majority of fights i took pardon
felt as if i was playing against an
opponent right by my side just the way
it should with so few players playing at
the moment it's too early to properly
judge the netcode and as a result
deliver a definitive verdict on the game
at large street fighter 5 has so little
single-player content and launch anyway
had the efficacy of its online
components is paramount in its current
state street fighter 5 busy me there are
no difficulty settings and it has a
laughably easy and short story campaign
for each character and by short I mean
that they last anywhere from two to four
flights from beginning to end in a case
of Fang graceful poison emitting
newcomer he has two fights against the
series ultimate villain and bison and
that's it based on my experience you can
complete everything in the story mode
for all characters and less than an hour
total by doing nothing more than
repeatedly sweeping the legs of your
opponents may have heard that binghis
the artist responsible for some of
capcom's most iconic artwork over the
years has created visuals for street
fighter 5 story mode but don't get
excited the quality of work here is a
far cry from the beautifully rendered
art bangus produce
in the 90s and the early 2000s the
storyboard quality images are
inconsistent with noticeable disparities
in detail from one image to the next at
least completing the story mode will net
you 100,000 fight one Street Fighter
fives in game currency based on Capcom's
plan for the future that sum is just the
right amount to purchase a new character
you also unlock a new costume for each
character by being their story mode
chapter but you unlock it for purchase
and in-game shop not for immediate use
the fact that the game ties everything
the currency of one form or another is
disappointing and we will fight money
you can purchase new characters and
story mode costumes using as any which
you purchase using real money beyond
training the inconsequential story mode
and one-on-one fights you're left with
survival mode and that's it survival
mode is serviceable offering four tiers
of consecutive fights but by allowing
you to trade points earned during fights
for health and power boosts it doesn't
provide a lasting challenge survival
mode lacks the excitement of one-on-one
battles and it's not distinct or
rewarding enough to pull you away from
fighting actual products for better or
worse street fighter 5 is a clean slate
it's got new mechanics characters move
sets and peculiarities but it doesn't
have a lot of meat for anyone who isn't
a die-hard competitive player street
fighter is known for being hardcore with
layers of systems beneath the surface
that most players miss that is as true
as ever with Street Fighter 5 but it's
good in a sense because it means there
is death to its systems that will keep
eager players engaged with the game as
they learn new tricks and develop new
strategies with the right tutorials and
activities at their disposal players
should be able to understand these over
time but I can't say with certainty when
these modes will become available
despite Capcom's current promises when
I'm playing street fighter 5 with
friends I'm completely lost in a heat of
the moment and that wouldn't be possible
if the game didn't play so well there's
an excellent foundation but it will be
hard to recommend street fighter 5 to
anyone about the most passionate fans
until the rest of the promised modes are
honored for now I'm going to keep
playing what is here and put the service
to the test for delivering our final
review and the coming days
you